en un embarazo de gemelos que tienen el
síndrome de transfusión de gemelo a
gemelo la sangre pasa de un gemelo a
otro
dentro del útero el feto recibe sangre a
través de los vasos sanguíneos del
cordón umbilical conectado al ombligo de
éste
el otro extremo del cordón umbilical
está adherido a la placenta un órgano
temporal que se encuentra dentro del
útero la capa externa de la placenta
denominada corium contiene muchos vasos
sanguíneos que transportan sangre desde
y hacia el cordón umbilical
el feto flota en una sustancia líquida
denominada líquido amniótico
una membrana fina denominada saco
amniótico rodea tanto al feto como el
líquido amniótico
si está embarazada de gemelos ellos
podrían compartir el líquido amniótico
porque ambos están en el mismo saco
o bien cada uno de ellos podría tener su
propio saco amniótico
estos gemelos pueden tener su propia
placenta
o pueden compartir una única placenta
a veces cuando los gemelos comparten una
placenta la sangre pasa entre ellos a
través de los vasos sanguíneos de la
placenta
esta afección poco común se denomina
síndrome de transfusión de gemelo a
gemelo o tts
en el síndrome de transfusión de gemelo
a gemelo uno de los gemelos denominado
gemelo receptor recibe demasiada sangre
mientras que el otro denominado gemelo
donante recibe muy poca
cuando esto ocurre el exceso de líquido
en la sangre del gemelo receptor se
filtra del cuerpo en forma de orina esta
pasa al saco amniótico lo que hace que
éste sea grande
el síndrome de transfusión de gemelo a
gemelo ocurre sólo en un pequeño
porcentaje de gemelos idénticos que
comparten una sola placenta
también es una complicación poco
frecuente que se da entre guisos o en
otros casos de embarazo múltiple se
desconoce la causa
las complicaciones que pueden producirse
a causa del síndrome de gemelos gemelos
o un parto prematuro
una afección denominada hidropesía que
es la retención de líquido de uno o
ambos gemelos o la muerte de uno o ambos
gemelos
además uno ambos gemelos pueden
desarrollar una parálisis cerebral o
cualquier otro tipo de daño cerebral
después del nacimiento
las opciones de tratamiento del síndrome
de transfusión de gemelo a gemelo
incluyen amniocentesis evacuado horas
ablación láser selectiva
o coagulación selectiva del cordón
si debe realizarse una amniocentesis
evacuado ahora se utilizará una aguja
para drenar el líquido alrededor del
gemelo que posee exceso de líquido
amniótico es probable que este
procedimiento deba a repetirse
durante la ablación láser selectiva se
sellan los vasos sanguíneos que permiten
que la sangre pase entre los gemelos con
un láser
si debe realizarse una coagulación
selectiva de cordón uno de los cordones
umbilicales se cerrará con corriente
eléctrica o con un láser esto se realiza
cuando la ablación láser no es posible o
cuando se cree que uno de los gemelos no
sobrevivirá
si tiene alguna inquietud acerca del
síndrome de transfusión de gemelo a
gemelo durante el embarazo busca
atención en un centro especializado con
experiencia su obstetra puede
proporcionarle una derivación